es geht um die geschichte einer mörderin
die den titel figur abgibt eine junge
frau die als kind bereits weg gegeben
würde in ein touristisches kloster und
dort zur fr 10 ausgebildet wurde von
einer nonne sie ist schneller als der
wind macht aber nichts was man sonst aus
martial arts film kennt das im blick die
luft fliegt und zwischen bäumen hin und
herfliegt und so das alles nicht es
bleibt alles im rahmen einer gewissen
glaubwürdigkeit der film ist von einer
solchen überirdischen schönheit und der
ist an solchen raffinesse und in einer
solchen detailgenauigkeit gearbeitet
gleichzeitig so verließen inszeniert
dass man den eindruck hat wie im traum
dass man gar nicht genau weiß jetzt wie
lange gucke ich mir das eigentlich an
sind das drei minuten oder sind es 30
oder sind es 30 stunden
worum es uns geht ist diese epoche
neuntes jahrhundert in china auf dem
land auferstehen zu lassen und er tut es
auf eine wunderbare weise in welcher
martial arts film fängt damit an dass
wir zwei esel grasen sehen noch dazu in
schwarz-weiß dieser hier ja und das ist
eigentlich das tolle es geht nicht in
dieser geschichte von obwohl es der
hintergrund ist geht es nicht um die
frage überlebt das große chinesische
reich oder sagen sich die provinzen los
sondern es geht um die frage gewinnt
diese frau diese mörderin ihre freiheit
und das ist sehr spannend und es ist
wunderschön mit anzuschauen